έρκονται εμές τουτον το χοράφι ναδούν τούτα τα πλάσματα που διούν τούτε στις πατάδες που
δρόμε και χερούμαστε κάθενύχ τα κάθε ομέσημέρι με στο πιατο αςσκεφτούμε πόσο σεβασμό πρέπει εμείς
να γυρίζουμε να αντικρίζουμε τούτα ταπλάσματα γιατί όχι δηλαδή να πάει ένας βασι λιας του
μια βασίλισσα στο χωράφι διαδή κίνημάνα που εθορε τον γιών τς εκαμάρων έτοπου τους κόπους
της ένα ξίζει τον κόπο να πά ένας βασιλιάς να τος διεμείς γιατί να τοδούμε
διαφορετικά θελα πάμε ξανάστις πυρκαγές αλλά πρόαθελασε πρό ενα άλλον κεφάλεο εδέκκαι σχέσς μαρις παναγι
του σήμερα με την επα ισκέσιμο με την εβαία και είναι ι σχέσι που που
είχαούτοση άλας είναι στενή μιλώμε των πρόεδρο του κόμματος επώ τεχιαστεί μετα στελέχει μεταμέλι του
κόμματος δηλαδί ύριμανιαδέκλέμε τώρα ποχωρήσει από τις τήριξης των ικό χριστό δουλεδη μαρία παναγιά του
θα μίνει στο κεβενηνικό σχήμα επιδή αυτή η ερώτηση γι αυτή περίπτωση δεν υπάρχει αυτή
τη στιγμή στοτραβες υπάρχει ρόγος να την απαντήσουμε τά να πάμε τότε στς δημοσκοποίσεις τα
ποσοστάτη εδεγιατί υπάρχει υτή πτώσει στα ποσωστά να ξπάντα τα η εδξει της δημοσκοποίσει σε
εδείχνε χαμηλά ποσωστά είναι ανάλογα με το που γίνεται γιπου λαμβάνεται το δεχμα και πάντα
στα αποτελέσματα τον εκλόγον πολύ διαφοριτικά όπότα ταξίνα να ένα εργαλείον τη στιγμής η δημοσκοπήσεις
που σίγουρα εχρήσημα ααλλά είναι κάρπι που πρόβληματίζει τη μάρια μάρα για το η επόμενη
μέρα της εδεκδεμε προβληματίζει υπό την άποψη του προβλήματος μεενδιαφέρει πως ενδιαφέρει το κάθεμένος της
εδέκ επειδή οι δημοσκοπίσεις δγνοις τις βουλευτικές του ιεξισο κόμματα σήμερα είναι στη βουλή να
μην είναι να